[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 129 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mok Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick how are you
doing Melanie I'm doing good mark how
are you I'm very well good very well you
know it's funny I talked to somebody
recently on your team and they were like
I listened to one of your podcasts and
it was when you both were sick that's
right mark is finally well it did
anyways so mark this week we are going
to be talking with Mandy Waite who is on
our team and in our developer relations
team and she runs one of the groups and
she talks to us all about developer
relations and what it is and how to
think about it ya know super interesting
chat definitely yep but as always we
always start with the cool thing of the
week and we end with our question of the
week and the question for this week is
that on May 25th as some of you may be
aware especially for all the privacy
notices that you might be getting in
your inbox yeah gdpr has gone into
effect and so we wanted to touch on that
briefly in terms of google cloud
platform and what that means for our
group and Google cloud platform so we
will do that at the end sounds good yeah
and we also are coming out of the
Memorial weekend for this podcast so
hopefully everybody's having a nice
break or has had a nice break yes
awesome so let's get stuck into our cool
things of the week this one I like a lot
this is really neat basically we have a
blog post an article and documentation
and stuff you can play with for better
cost controls we the Google cloud
billing programmatic notifications short
answer being if you've ever been
thinking what happens if my costs just
suddenly skyrocket and I don't happen to
notice them that would be bad I would
not appreciate that on Google cloud so
what we can do now is set up
programmatic notifications for cost
control on Google cloud this is good
this is really important it's really
cool so right now it's it up so that
basically a pub/sub notification occurs
but we have examples set up so that you
can go and read them and put the links
in the show notes basically to fire off
a cloud function which could then do
things like set a notification to slack
possibly send you an email you could
even do stuff like just turn off billing
or possibly turn off certain resources
within your project to help slow down
the amount of costs that you're having
depending on what it is that you're
building really the world's your oyster
but it is really cool now that you have
this sort of warning system in place and
or you know something you might want to
automatically do actions on - right yeah
the post helps you understand what
you can do to set up these types of
notifications and makes it easy for you
which is good because I agree with you
it's important for us to have a way to
monitor and not go over a budget okay so
the other cool thing of the week is one
of our colleagues gave Weiss has written
about a cool IOT project he worked on
which was in conjunction with firebase
and so he wanted to he's a musician on
the side and there's a sound room that
he wanted to be able to have an
understanding of when it's available and
what it isn't so he built out an IOT
device using a Raspberry Pi and a
passive infrared sensor to detect motion
and determine when the room is in use
and he was doing this with a motion
sensor to avoid capturing sound or
capturing video in that room but to
definitely detect is it in use and how
often is it in use and he shows how to
build that out with the actual IOT
device as well as combine it with
firebase to track the data itself so I
should check out the blog post and see
if you want to play around with motion
detector yourself nice yeah another fun
thing Alexi who is on our team as well
we've mentioned him before he does a
this week in Google cloud platform blog
post one of the things out of that that
I thought was particularly interesting
recent IO attendees were able to
complete in person code labs at the
event but those code labs are actually
available as well there's 25 plus
updated cloud code labs you can get
we'll put the link in the short notes
it's GCO / io / code labs if you click
on the cloud category you can get the
cloud ones but all the other ones are
there as well also we'll put a link in
there that there's the also the complete
list of free cloud code labs they remain
available as well jierou / code labs /
cloud there's role available so if
you're looking for some free training or
some free how to's on how to build stuff
on cloud on Google cloud specifically
we'll put those links in the show notes
and you can have it done that's great
and the last thing we're going to
mention is that there is a kubernetes
podcast if you haven't noticed one that
is explicitly about kubernetes and
that's being run by Adam Glick and Craig
box it will put the link in the show
notes but they have been releasing
podcasts every week so far for the last
month on Tuesdays when they usually
release and so far you know that we had
Parris Pittman couple months ago now
come on and that was their first guest
and since then they've touched on you
know coop flow and G Weiser
stackdriver kubernetes monitoring so
check this out if you're looking for
more information kubernetes but it's a
really hot domain to remember easy
kubernetes podcast.com good sigh simple
yeah that'll be it'll be all your things
kubernetes will still keep talking about
Karen at ease of course of course I'm on
the show cuz marks here but if you want
more if this isn't enough for you you
will have another avenue to check out
excellent wasn't well shall we go chat
with mandy then I think it's time let's
do it this week's podcast we are
thrilled to have with us Mandy Waite
who's a manager on the dev rel team and
Mandy thanks for joining us thank you
for having me I'm glad our schedules
finally aligned now that we have you
here can you tell the people who are
listening a little bit about who you are
what you do so my name is Mandy Waite I
am developer advocate I'm not actually
on a manager ladder currently I'm a
developer advocate at Google cloud I run
a team of infrastructure and operations
advocates or working with a wide variety
of communities such as DevOps sre cloud
native cloud native ops potentially
security and networking in the future
we're still growing the teams over
focused very much on DevOps and cloud
native currently I've been around at
Google for nearly eight years now I came
from some Microsystems where I used to
do a kind of similar role but which was
much more marketing in mind trying to
get people to adopt our stuff and I got
a job with Google working on AdWords as
a developer advocate that was
interesting extremely great technical
challenge to be a PID ID was API is
extremely complicated and it's a lot of
fun and he has to scale and understand
and that was really really useful to me
was kind of background I had was a scale
in systems and scaling api's was new to
me but you had very much the same kind
of similar problems that I've been
facing in the past with Sun did I move
to cloud in 2012 at the end of 2012 and
I've been on cloud ever since and we've
grown from a small team of people a mix
of roles before to a small team of
developer advocates so a team of a
number of areas over time I think it's
46 so we have a large team now we
generally no longer service developer
advocates was much more aligned with
being advocates or cloud advocates
although we do developer advocacy as
well
for me it's much more around not really
hovering developer
anymore is more about talking to other
communities ones that are very very
important to us when it comes to making
sure that we had the best possible
products and that would be the devops
community cloud native cloud native
operations communities sre is a great
story lots of people are starting to
look at doing necessary security for the
future probably security across the
board if there's all different aspects
of Technology so that's what we're doing
currently as I say I manage a team of
about 10 people on my team currently and
your team focuses on your saying you're
on infrastructure and operations right
infrastructure operations yeah it's a
very general term I know it's the best
term but it seems this one we landed on
originally called it operations in
infrastructure but somehow I got turned
around I'm not sure why I don't forgive
any matters they could be the DevOps
team or a DevOps cloud native team but
infrastructure operations seems they
cover it more it's definitely not
developer centric so I'm gonna ask you
the hard question then because how do
you define developer relations yeah so
interesting question to be honest I mean
the fact that we work with other
communities other than developers gives
us an interesting challenge because some
umbrella term that we can use to
reference all of these communities that
we work with developer community to
DevOps community the data science
community there is no really good
umbrella term and we tend to fall back
on technical communities as being the
umbrella term but it's not a good one
we're still fundamentally developer
relations but we've just really kind of
overloaded the term developer to mean
all of these other communities as well
and so developer relations is actually
making sure that we had the best
possible products and the best possible
experience for people using the products
as possible and also making sure that we
communicate what we have take our
narratives and our messages on the road
and Soudan to people help them
understand how they can solve their
problems with our products because
actually extremely important but not
forcing products and on people's throats
saying hey we had this thing you should
use this it's not around giving people
put up pictures it's about talking about
how we can solve problems using our
technology and often that's a case of
meeting people where they are when you
have something like now because that
involves using tooling that they're
familiar with already with our cloud
product so they'll be using something
like Jenkins to do build pipelines and
such like CIC deed and
we want Jenkins to work really well and
a great example of that would be
infrastructure as code that kind of
thing having people making sure they use
chef and puppet and terraformed and that
those things work perfectly well with
our cloud platform they're all is also
an aspect of being opinionated as well
don't say like Google do things this way
and this is what we've been doing with
kubernetes for a long time so four years
ago we started talking about kubernetes
it was new to us apart from the fact
that we knew how things worked
internally at Google with Borg and I
think you've had John Milton talking
about board before
Borg was really really interested in to
many of us and taking that message out
on the road to show people hey have you
ever considered in this way it was on
the back end of the container revolution
and my message back then was very much
hey I have all of these containers now
what do I do with him and cumulus was a
solution to that but it was it was
highly opinionated but he was also a new
paradigm as well and I think people have
adopted it at scale and I think is a
kind of a really good inflection curve
showing adoption of communities and I
like to see more of that happening but
being opinionated about something you
have to be careful with it because you
can't always change the way people feel
about something meeting people where
they are is very very important but if
you have a better way then you should be
showing them how they can be successful
doing it that way but without dismissing
what they're doing currently and making
it seem like what they do may be trivial
compared to what we're doing
build it like Google might be a great
message but we had to be respectful the
fact that people build things our own
way currently and if this helps them and
solve some of their problems for them
then that's great and we can take those
messages out and people will listen to
them but we have to meet people where
they are and keep the opinionation a
little bit more low-key so you were
saying about how this being developer
relations what comprises of developer
relations
well comprises developer relations
people well so part of the reason I'm
asking is Mark and I officially
developer advocates and I know we have a
number of different roles within the
team and so I'm basically setting this
up to say hey what are some of the roles
what are some of the makeup of the teams
that we have yeah I think I don't know I
was being flippant but in people as well
so I think it's very important that you
know that the people aspect of it is so
massive the importance of this role it
is very much about working with people
and being at a commune
wouldn't be able to understand the needs
empathy is a huge word or whether we use
a lot another word is really important
is trust
so trust an ember feared very much
people things and not related to
technology in any meaningful way
I think it's probably very easy to be in
technology and not have a lot of trust
and not to have a lot of empathy and I
think one of the keys have been
successful in developer relations has
been after have those skills not
necessarily develop them I think you can
develop empathy I always go back to
something I saw when I was working with
a TV rental company back in the UK a
long long time ago when I was 16 years
old and they just have a sign on their
the wall next to the reception area
saying be sincere and I always said you
can't be sincere you either are or
aren't and I think it's some of that
with empathy
you know empathy is something you
potentially can develop but it is deep
it is fundamental you know you can't
make people think you have them but if
you wanted me to do all you don't and I
think have an empathy is something that
I see across the whole of the team and I
think that's really really important for
us and the trust part of it is also
implicit of them so what benefits does
Google cloud get out of the relationship
that it has with its developer relations
team like why do we even exist yes I
began 20 years probably doing this work
people have always known we were very
important and not really quite known why
or being prepared to take the risk of
not having their Braille backups Sun
Microsystems we used to be moved from
software organizations to marketing
organizations because people knew that
we were absolutely necessary but not
quite sure where we fitted in to the
organization so why do we have Deborah
well I actually asked this question
there was some people a couple years ago
we were doing some strategizing around
things and I asked the question what
would happen if there was made everyone
you know I suppose very much we would
have voice products we would have worse
developer experiences and I said I felt
the answer was that the product scenes
would create their own Devereux it was
an essential role within a team we were
a product seemed to have some kind of
devrel function some PM's many PM's
feel that they have a good handle on
what customers are doing and such like
and not all of them feel very close to
their actual community abusers it could
be in this case a DevOps community in my
team order
developer community and they know that
they need to go out and get that
information they also need to know that
they need to take their messages out and
show people how they can be successful
with those products at their building so
they would fundamentally build their own
devrel team and if you look at that
scale across a large number of products
and going back to when I started it was
things like AdWords web chrome Android
you would have lots of different
different functions
growing up in parallel and commonalities
scale make it sensible to pull them all
out and put them together in one place I
would argue that there are always
problems around doing their role in a
cookie cutter away for a specific
product it needs to be different than
home for each different product I think
that's extremely important to understand
and it also depends where our product is
in its product lifecycle it depends on
your audience as well so those
considerations are important but I think
having a dev role team we can benefit
from large scale programs the kind of
mentality and the mindset of the people
that we hire gives us a huge edge when
it comes to doing Devereux as opposed to
having a product team building their own
team so I think that's why we have Debra
all currently yeah I think that because
I know you one of the next questions you
can ask me about how we measure it
interesting yeah well okay how do you
measure it what are ways that you can
determine it's impactful I've given this
a lot of thought a lot of whatever it is
I think there is always consequences of
the work that we do the number of people
who watch a video to length of time that
they watch the video the amount of
engagement they have with the things
that we produce and they could be
looking at a medium post or reading a
blog post I think those things are very
easy to measure and capture I think
there is a danger around having a goal
around those numbers always I don't
think it's a good thing to have a goal
around a number to say we should have 1
million video views within q1 or q2 I
don't think that's a very good way of
doing it but it is a good metric and so
if you look at the work that you do and
the things that you do some matches are
gonna bubble out of there and you can
push them up to people but they
shouldn't be the reason why you're doing
it so the reason you would do a video
series was to get important information
out to people or to drive some strategic
goal that you really care about and
you've agreed with the product teams and
ultimately the metrics will drop acid
and you can report up on them and you
can say we did 500 events or see
and events last year we did a hundred
and fifty videos and we had X number of
views and X number of in-person outreach
was done but I don't think they're the
numbers that we should be driving I
think one thing this is a little bit
dangerous but I think it's interesting
to think about this more is done
products tend to have a graph of
adoption or usage utilization or
efficacy usefulness and that kind of
thing and those graphs you naturally
want them to go up into the right
probably not linearly like exponential
growth you possible but I think your
products are going up and sort of right
and you have a devrel function now I
think that shows that your devrel
function is working and doing things
correctly you might be tempted to say
well it's implied ever a function away
and see if it flattens but you're not
going to want to do that so there is
always that danger you're not quite sure
you can't necessarily attribute a word
that Devereaux does to don't happen to
your right curve but I think it's
important to understand it it's a
fundamental part of all of your process
of building the product and bringing it
to market is that you have a devrel
function that's ultimately driving the
product to be better based on people's
feedback and you're showing people how
to use it and making sure people are
aware of it I think awareness is a great
thing but awareness is so difficult it's
so so difficult it still seems to me
that there's a large number of people
out there a large percentage of people
not a number a large percentage of
people that I've not heard about Google
Cloud products and that's it seems
strange considering amount of work that
we've done but I just think that there
are a large number of people out there
and I think we have to be aware of that
and not a lot of people work in the
environments where they don't get
exposed so all of these things very much
and so maybe they don't know of it
because of that I'd like everybody to
know about our products and how to be
successful with those products I'd like
to be getting feedback from everybody
said that we can bring that back to the
product teams and make our products
better I don't know how we can reach
that I think we probably need to
continue to grow endeavour always as a
product teams grow I think we like
behind a little bit as the products grow
Debra is always a little bit behind the
curve when it comes to adding more
people so in terms of impact what are
some of the activities you've seen that
have had the most impact that's a really
good question and you didn't give that
one to me
is a good question and I think people do
things in different ways I think the
great thing about our deverel team is
original cookie cutter approach they're
doing it we do it differently we do it
based on our own skills our own
experiences the things that we're good
at we do it based on our own products
now I'm communities that we're trying to
reach and our own goals and strategies
as well so I see lots of different
things and lots of different success
stories I think having a podcast is a
great idea so thank you without ideas it
should be no as all mark I have no idea
that was maybe was your dog it was
Francis good I'll get him but we got
very good at doing videos and we felt in
the past two years ago that we weren't
very good at doing videos and they'll be
much better at doing videos we had a lot
of attention for our videos where I saw
very sick things and bright at a point
we've socialized them very well we get
lots of views and nothing that's really
important that's really impactful I
think that for open-source projects
which is a new really a new thing around
doing advocacy for Oh Debra for
generally I went single out advocacy but
just devrel generally is that it's a
different kind of way of doing things
and I look at somebody like Jana Dogen
on my team who's working on open census
and she's really involved in the
community she was a sweet on the
community she was doing lots of
contributions to it but she understands
exactly what the mission is and what the
goal is and she understands the
community and their needs and she
understands what you would like to get
out of it and she's doing a different
kind of dev'reaux dare we were consensus
that's another different way of doing
and another different way of being
successful so I think he's really a case
of constantly exploring and constantly
adapting I had this goal I want to
achieve this which maybe I wanna grow
adoption of big query constantly
thinking about new ways of doing it
maybe going on Reddit and game millions
and billions of people to actually talk
about your product which is some done
our team does Felipe yeah Felipe yeah so
yeah so I think there's lots of great
things that people do and I'm just
hoping that there's more innovation
because you look at it and you think
we've done all of that everywhere we can
all the different ways of doing there
Rob and someone's going to come up with
something new
Oh actually gentle is currently doing
live stream code in twitch for devrel
effectively in there I really like that
I think that's going to be a new model
it peels so a different way of thinking
I tend to think that people change as
they grow with technology the way people
think about things is probably different
than the way I used to think about them
when I was young
because just technologies they're never
present nothing livestreaming seems to
be a really big deal for people nowadays
well Marcus doing that and so is Holden
actually asked a few of us that's great
Chris Broadfoot on the go team DB
livestream is a new one say these are
the things we wouldn't have predicted a
while back I'm hoping that next year
there'll be another really great
innovative way of actually doing this
kind of developer relations and getting
the message out to people maybe
something with IOT yeah so on a
practical note sort of you were talking
about this as well how like tailoring
the devrel experience for different
communities in different groups
you run the infrastructure and ops group
which is a very different community say
there may be the wider tech community
how have you seen basically the approach
for Deverell in that space be different
from say other communities that you've
worked in I think it's the DevOps
community I have a different need from
the more general developer community I
kind of struggle with saying that it
sounds because I think we've grown up
with developers we didn't develop
relations for 10 years 11 years or so
and it's easy to think that developers
and DevOps are different fundamentally
the way we should do messaging system is
different I think it's at the moment we
don't have very many people doing
developer relations for DevOps and so I
think the key here is to look to hire
people who are practitioners people who
actually come from that community a part
of that community and bring them onto
the team and have them advocate on
behalf of that community through our
product teams and also understand the
needs and help them solve their problems
because the problems that I community
have exactly the same problems that
they've had up till now and so I think
that's really really important and I'm
going to follow for now if we just could
just break the question a little bit
that I often find myself drawing to
people on a whiteboard something called
a trainer curve so Ben trainer has this
kerbin trainer is the guy who invented
sre at Google and we had his trainer
curve about how people with skills
change over time and I constantly draw
his picture whereby a practitioner would
have core practice new skills and maybe
not so much advocacy skills at the time
we start and that their practitioner
skills would wane over time in our
advocacy skills would improve and so I
have my own trainer curve whereby
advocacy skills are now much better than
practitioners girls and I think at times
you need to kick energy back into that
to say hey you need to go back to being
a prize
again it may well be that they feel
comfortable and that they're really on
it and they actually know what's going
on but I think I'm time to time you need
to step back and say okay what is my
community doing let me go back and be
one of them for a while and I'd like to
see us doing more of that I mean it
comes to practitioners so I think that's
really really helpful having
practitioners and keeping us
practitioner skills I think it's also
possible to pivot to a practitioner role
as well I think we had an evidence of
that on my team currently when it comes
to security which jen is doing as well I
think that's really really interesting I
think there's also a lot of space for
more generalists to grow up internet
spaces go on to learn from the
practitioners and to become
practitioners as well so having more
senior people as practitioners but
having more junior people as the people
who learn from them take their messages
on the road maybe not have the same kind
of recognition as they do but can help
with content and videos and such like
and I think those people are really
really key to it as well because there
are not that many practitioners in the
world and so if you want to have a
reasonably large team and good coverage
stand you're probably not going to be
able to do that just by hiring
practitioners so definitely get from
preciousness I had this conversation
with Adam Seligmann recently about trust
versus credibility and I do agree trust
is extremely important we need people to
trust our advocates when they talk to
them I know this person I trust what
they're telling me and at the same time
I'll put that team stakeholders as well
should trust them and trust them when
they bring stories and feedback back to
the pod it seems that say maybe you
should do it this way they trust that
person of you and they give it to
consideration
I know Trust in particular is very
valuable when it you can give them a
perspective and it's not necessarily
being driven by the product itself it's
being specifically driven by this is
what I know about the space this is what
I'm able to bring to the table about the
space yeah so when I was asking earlier
before about you know developer
relations at Google and what that looked
like a little part of why I had led down
the path to that question was I hear
developer evangelists as a term that's
constantly intermixed with developer
advocate so I'm curious what your
perspective is on these two terms and
you know how they relate and how they
don't relate yeah and a really
interesting question I think we're a
large company whoever large developer
relations team it's very easy for us to
kind of be very specific about what we
do when it comes to a role we can shape
the role to be
what it needs to be and so let's go back
a bit take one step is bi-directional
our role as AI because it's doing
evangelism effectively talking to people
what I think it's a different kind of
evangelism it's much more like sitting
down with people and holding their hands
and talking them through things learning
from them and having them learn from you
and she talked them through how you can
potentially solve their problems at that
point you may learn things that you
didn't know about the product and how it
works and what you can bring feedback
back to the product seems so it's not
really fundamentally evangelism Aldo
delivers a lot of that going to events
and doing outreach is very much a form
of evangelism and that the other end is
this kind of influence on the product
and bringing feedback like I'm making
cases right in what we call friction
logs which are things details somebody's
interactions with my products and some
of the problems that they may have had
raising bugs driving fixes showing
people what kind of impact is likely to
be achieved through addressing a
particular issue and I think you fascism
is that one half of that and I think
some teams some smaller debra team just
can't really afford to do both parts of
it it's much more about getting the
message out and so they focus more
specifically on the evangelism component
of it but I think advocacy is rooted in
that bi-directional thing whereby we
influence our product seams and we
influence how communities don't see a
question yes curious also to know your
thoughts on if people listen to say this
podcast or they've heard other things
about developer relations what have been
some paths or their path that you think
would be great for people who want to
get involved with developer relations
because it seems like a fairly niche
thing in some ways yeah really
interesting insight because the
practitioner way of thinking about it
it's interesting I mean obviously we're
hiring practitioners then they may not
come necessarily with advocacy skills
but they're going to want to want to do
that kind of work and when you interview
people and you ask them why developer
relations is always about I showing
people having work I like teaching
people I've always been like that always
you find that you look at their github
and it's all based on tutorials and such
like what I've been producing tutorials
you show people how to do things and
it's really interesting there are some
people have the mindset that I just want
to help people some people also once
they've experienced pain in the past and
I don't mean physical pain but the pain
that I experienced some Microsystems
when I was trying to make something
called opensolaris which was
from source version of Solaris work with
all of the Linux applications in rpms
and suchlike were out there and nothing
ever worked I would spend a lot of my
time google him for esoteric error
messages and nobody's ever seen this
problem before ever so I felt very much
I wanted to blog about that I wanted to
share that where people said that they
could find it if they ever hit that same
problem again they would be able to
solve it and every time that happened
I've blogged about it I've blogged about
it I blogged about it and I think that's
something that a lot of people like
doing he's like they don't want people
to experience the same kind of pain that
they've experienced and so that's
another reason to come into this kind of
role you want to make the world a better
place I use up my tagline for Twitter
was make the cloud a better place for
developers so I think some people just
want to do that the question was more
about paths into advocacy right but I
think you need that part of it you need
that mentality you've seen the best
speakers you know they're the ones
actually really care and do have empathy
for their audience and that's always
gonna be a case having empathy not
developing necessarily Waldo days
possible have an empathy be developers
is also key or your target audience and
I'm overloading that word developers
again which happens early where would
you want to see this field grow into how
do you want to see it evolve based on
what you've seen so far yeah that's a
really interesting question and to keep
testing for I want it to be bigger I
like the fact that it's different that
people do it differently and people
approach it differently I like it to be
continuously evolving I don't think
there's enough standardization around it
I would like to see it moving away from
being a marketing function which it
often is I don't think that's the best
place for
Deverell I would much bro see it rooted
in engineering principles I know that's
not always possible I'm not sure if I
have a strong opinion of that though I
don't know if I'm a strong opinion of
where I want it to go I want to have
influence when I'm what really
eventually in a world to be a better
place for people who are building thick
or doing thick and I think tech is on a
path that makes it very hard for us to
keep up it's likely to be asymptotic the
closer we get to having really good
experiences for people using say
probably the further up and away from us
it gets and makes it more difficult
through your experience your history of
working in tech
I'm just curious as a side thing what is
it one of the technologies that you've
seen that really you were so excited
about when it finally came and you felt
like it completely had this huge impact
that you wouldn't have imagined or
expected yeah I think I've already
mentioned it contained the scheduling
humanities doctor was I watched Solomon
hikes give me the talk at dot scale
which is happening in Paris least we can
all we'll be there watching Solomon
hikes talk about docker in 2013 was
really really exciting comparison to
containers shipping containers and such
languages it just really moved me it was
really a fantastic it's a great event
nationally and having containers was
great but having an ability to scheduled
room like the way we do at Google was
even better for me it was like I really
get this I really understand how this
works and I really want to make this a
thing I became very determined to make
it a thing and hopefully I made some
small contribution to that era so I know
you did kubernetes was very much nothing
that made me most excited these kind of
paradigms just although on the whole I
probably would say cloud native
generally the whole principles behind
cloud native are probably more important
as kubernetes becomes more of the new
infrastructure that can publish down
into the substrate as I used to describe
it to people and things get built on top
of it because it's an enabler for new
things I think we can do services better
now that we have things like this do and
things like that don't come along
service meshes generally and all of the
other ecosystem components that have
coming up around Kuban it is just really
really exciting and I think it just
changes the way you think about it I'd
love to get away from traditional
infrastructure completely and just using
containers and not worry about where
they run excellent are we hiring at the
moment I think they're always very large
at Google and we have lots of
opportunities hire people here there's
always some job description open for a
role with endeavor all at Google my team
we have a couple currently they're
coming and going and such like
we have pipelines that get full up and
suchlike but yeah we're definitely
hiring
cloud advocate for DevOps potentially or
cloud advocate for cloud natives I kind
of mean really the best place to go for
information around that is careers or
google.com which has all of our listings
there you can also do um me on Twitter
with much better and are going to be
published yes we are definitely focusing
that yeah so you can also do me on
Twitter as well
well I can say it it's a pretty great
team I can't complain too much
definitely so Mandy I know we're getting
close to time but is there any place
you're gonna be at outside of Paris that
you'll be speaking at or you'll be
attending that you want people to come
and say hi let me think
not really I don't get so many talks
anymore which is a shame I like to even
talk so I don't have any specific plans
I'm gonna be at various different events
cloud next events cloud summit events
that we have coming up I'll be in London
probably in Tokyo as well certainly been
in San Francisco but we have in July
which is July 23rd I believe cloud next
in San Francisco
yes definitely anything else that you
wanted to share around developer
relations that we did narrow to cover I
don't think so I think drinking lots of
water to make sure your boys can hold up
long periods of time because my voice
just doesn't hold up very well you'll
always find me in videos with a bottle
of water man so it's very hard with my
voice to survive a long talk that's my
big tip is always have a bottle of water
with you like that well we appreciate
you coming on the podcast thank you so
much for sharing your thoughts on
developer relations and yeah thank you
so much welcome and thank you for
running the podcast it's much
appreciated it's a great thing to listen
to and really really really enjoy it
thank you
how pleasure thank you Mandy always a
pleasure to chat with you thank you so
much for coming on the podcast and talk
to us about your perspective on
developer relations
I'm always insightful definitely agree
and I'm glad we finally got to it too
because I know we'd been trying to get
that into the podcast sooner rather than
later so Marc question of the way the
question yeah so as you were mentioning
before May 25th gdpr came into effect
and that's the general data protection
regulation in the EU
thank you but where do I go to learn
more about GDP are in regards to Google
cloud platform and the effect it has and
all that all the stuff that I need to
know I am NOT a lawyer you were not
neither of us are yeah and this is a
regulation in the EU law on data
protection and privacy for all
individuals within the European Union it
addresses the export of personal data
outside of the EU so we are including
the shownotes a couple of links we have
around you know how information in
relation to Google cloud and general
data protection regulation you know
they've got some information around
complying with the gdpr may require
changes across your business this is
just more general guidelines to keep in
mind when you're looking at GDP are you
know and they've got some tips and
pointers especially like product and
feature guidance as well and it's worth
noting these guides are both G suite and
Google cloud platform right yes under
both of them they'll talk about you know
it's great especially when you're using
like two-step verification to reduce
risk of unauthorized access by asking
users for additional proof of identity
you know that it's good to help include
those functionality when you're thinking
about this regulation but you can check
out the resources that we're going to
provide and we're also including a link
that is a data protection fact sheet for
citizens of the EU and it gives a nice
summary and pseudo visualizes some of
the key rights that now exist and how to
understand them yeah excellent so
Melanie where are you going what are you
doing what are you up to what's going on
I am gonna be speaking at a joint event
that the women in machine learning in
data science and pilotes have organized
in San Francisco at door - on path to
data science on June 26 and once the
meetup invite us out I will definitely
include that in our show notes but yeah
that's where I'm gonna be and mark what
about you so literally the day this
comes out I will be presenting that
evening at the monthly SF and game
developer community I'll be doing my
presentation called
you can't just add more servers which is
the point where you normally make fun of
my accent and say you love saying that -
you just can't no actually that's just
how I talk now you like saying Mac
that's fine but I'll also highlight i've
been streaming a lot on twitch as well I
had a really fun one recently where I
did a bunch of stuff I've got I'll put a
link to the YouTube video actually
because that'll hang around but I've
been streaming writing a code I had a
fun one recently where we did some fun
work around wrapping an existing
dedicated game so ever basically we took
an existing process and then we
intercepted the standardout and then
using the text that was coming out of
the standardout we just implemented some
actions to occur it was a really nice
sort of exploration of interfaces and go
actually I think it worked really nicely
cool it was cool so I'll just highlight
that because I thought that was a
particularly if do you one I'm glad
you're having fun with twitch in the
streaming it's awesome
mark I think that's it for us for this
week yeah Melanie thank you very much
for joining me for yet another week on
the podcast thank you thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]